thank god the ukrainians
surprised everybody
they surprised me they surprised putin
and the kremlin they surprised the bide
administration they surprised the
european union not with the fact that
they would resist
we knew that
we had the orange revolution in 2004 we
had maidan in 2013-14
where they rose up against
a domestic tyrant
and they were willing to die on behalf
of their country then let alone against
the foreign tyrant invading their
country right so we knew they would
resist we didn't know just how
successful certainly i didn't know they
would be on the battlefield it's been
breathtaking to watch
that sacrifice that gift
enabled the west to rediscover itself to
rediscover its power to revive itself to
say to hell with this energy dependence
in the long term the hell with this
money laundering and reputation
laundering the hell with this running
back and forth to moscow
to try to see what putin needs in order
for him to feel respected what
appeasement he needs right so so
we'll see if it endures
but this
shift
comes from the ukrainians and so it's no
longer getting away with murder lex and
we thank the ukrainians for that the
people and the leadership
and uh
the the the separate factions that make
up ukraine uniting the it's the
unification the uniting against the
common enemy yes and standing up
before anyone knew that they would be
backed by all of these other nations by
this money and all this kind of stuff
standing there
especially with the president zelinski
where it makes uh total sense to flee
he stood his ground
and selected let's take that point that
you just raised which is a deep and
fundamental point and i thank you for
that
do you guys hear that though i think
that was a compliment there we go let's
go
lex so let's scare unification
and it's a mutual honor
so um
ukraine before the war is run by a tv
production company
right you're one guy running this
fantastic incredible podcast there's 20
guys or so running a country the size of
ukraine yeah and and one's a producer
and one's like a makeup person and
one's a video editor and they're
fantastically talented people
if your country is a tv production
so before the war zolensky had what 25
approval rating
and he couldn't get much done and it
wasn't working he got elected with 73 as
you know and then he was down to 20
that's a pretty big drop
and so you're thinking maybe having a
major large size 40 million plus
population european country run by a tv
production company is not the best
choice
and then what do we see
we see president zielinski decides
to risk his life on behalf of his
country ukraine he decides to stay in
the capital
he's not going to flee
he they're going to stay and fight
and he could be killed he can die it's a
decision where he put his life on the
line
obviously
he's jewish descent
russian speaking
childhood and upbringing
russian speaking jewish descent puts his
life on the line for the country of
ukraine
it's a pretty big message don't you
think
and it's crucial
and it turns out not only that lex
but they're good at tv
they're good at information war
and in a war yeah it's a tv production
company and a tv personality those
that's exactly what you want running a
country
because they're crushing in the
information war and he's spectacular
european parliament
u.s congress israeli parliament there's
no room
on zoom let alone in person that he
can't win over he's just so effective
you know this is the first time reality
tv
has been about reality
instead of fake
reality tv is just this completely fake
nonsense but zelensky this is real
reality tv
and and and he means it
and and the nation is behind him
and and they're just as courageous and
just as ingenious in many ways
and it's spectacular
and so yeah
who saw that coming i didn't see that
coming lex in fact dubai didn't we talk
about putin's miscalculation the bide
administration as you alluded to
offered him an exit from the country
they didn't say you know you want to
stand and fight we'll back you
they said we'll get you out
you want to come now
and famously you know that quote
right what he said
about how he doesn't need a ride
remember that yeah moment
the byte administration was poised to do
another afghanistan moment
that ignominious exit from afghanistan
was almost what happened in ukraine
when by the administration offered him
that ride out of there and fortunately
he declined and helped rally and the
people from below also rallied to stop
the invader
without the presidency and without the
government in ukraine
saving the bide administration and and
the european leaders
who latched on fortunately they had the
presence of mind to latch on to this
gift this this
bravery and ingeniousness of of zelinski
and the rest of the ukrainians and
flipped and decided to support ukraine's
resistance
you know first with 5000 helmets only
as the germans initially promised and
now with really heavy weapons
and so that's something that wasn't
foreseen
i certainly didn't foresee that i
foresaw the ukrainian society being
courageous and resisting but i didn't
foresee a television production company
being exactly what you want to run a
country in a war
a president
zielenski
willing to sacrifice lay down his life
and rallying others in the country to do
that
and then the country being so effective
not just at
a courage but at battlefield resistance
to the russian invasion so i stand
corrected by the ukrainians and i'm
ecstatic that i didn't that i was wrong
that i was proven wrong and like i said
there's
clear factions of the west and the east
of ukraine and here's a person that like
you said was in the high 20s low 30s
percentage
approval
in the country before the war and now
was able to use in the 90s in the 90s
he's in the 90
approval rating i mean i i think they
stopped doing
the uh
the polling once he hit 91 or whatever
it was in the previous poll i think they
all understood that that for now they
didn't need any more polling
that it's pretty clear the nation so 25
percent to 90 something percent
and and and just like the 25 percent was
deserved
the 90 something percent is also
deserved fully deserved
you